[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's that kind of comedy
podcast time where we talk about comedy
and death and answer your questions and
bring you all the week's news on both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon how are you doing
John not great
not not brilliantly to be honest with
you the biggest problem I have in my
life right now Hank and this is going to
come as a huge surprise to you is that I
had an oral surgery yesterday and it was
complicated and painful and it's just
it's not my favorite thing I don't love
dental pain but I have it a lot I also
don't love dental pain and I don't have
it a lot you well in general I find you
to be a very lucky person and also right
now if you brag about no no no dental
pain I am going to reach through the
ether and strangle you we did the
patreon chat just before this and you
told the story of why you are having
your current dental pain and I just want
to tell everyone
just in case John doesn want to tell
that whole story right now it's real bad
and you and I'm so sorry I'm not gonna
tell the story again but it is really
bad I'm not gonna tell it mostly because
it would lead to a not insignificant
number of our listeners vomiting yeah I
mean we are like a hundred thousand
people you tell a story like that you
know somebody's gonna to get a little
bit of something coming up oh well yep
it's it's a beautiful day here in
Missoula Montana by which I mean it's
gross but in comparison to other planets
I mean perfect outside it's so true I
mean just the fact of having weather is
really actually actually most planets
have weather they have significant
weather and in fact I would say more
weather than we have here on earth just
like Jupiter's weather basically would
take your skin right off so I mean Venus
is weather would would even faster you'd
basically be that sounds lovely
you basically be cooked but in a way
that would be an
if you lived on Venus too delicious
would you like a short poem for the day
huh short jaunt too bad I don't have one
let's move on to questions from our
listeners see what it do you want to do
the one that I posted on Twitter earlier
today uh I think I don't know if you
know this about me but I am no longer on
Twitter I know so you don't know about
this wonderful poem I wrote oh my god
you tweeted so many times today what is
it like I tweeted to feel that the world
needs to hear from you multiple times a
day actually that's not fair because I
tweet all the time as Leon Maas is not
on social media hiatus no no no just
because I quit Twitter doesn't mean that
Leon must also quit Twitter is it is it
the one about water yeah I dreamt of
dozens of glasses of cool fresh water
when I woke I was still thirsty a dream
that they impose that I wrote inside of
a dream after waking up from a dream in
which I found a bunch of glasses of cool
fresh water because I was really really
thirsty I mean that's that's inception
level stuff right there somebody was
planting something inside of your
subconscious yeah I think I want to ask
a question from our listeners okay John
that subject and verb did not agree so
first I want to apologize to our
listeners for my terrible grammar and
then I want to ask this question it
comes from Michael who writes Dear John
and Hank I've been thinking a lot about
mottos lately because I want to design a
tattoo with a coat of arms and the best
ones coats of arms I mean not tattoos
always have mottos I've mostly settled
on above all compassion but I was
wondering if either of you had better
ideas for a motto do you have a personal
motto should I translate my motto into
Latin mystified by mottos and Michael
first of all I gotta say John the way
that you said above all compassion it
did not feel like what like the comma
was where it should be so it's above all
compassion not you are I am not awful my
mouth hurts
I'd say memento mori that's a pretty
good it's a pretty good motto and it's
also true I have actually composed a
list of like my top ten
in Latin motto Oh oh my goodness I might
have over prepared for this podcast
while I was suffering from some dental
pain so my wife's grandfather had a huge
coat of arms in his house like a massive
probably seven foot tall coat of arms
and beneath it in Latin in like fancy
script it was written illegitimate
carborundum do you know what that means
no it means don't let the bastards get
you down that's number one prefer you've
also got on here a homo homini lupus
John man is a wolf toward man is that
that one man is a wolf to man it's true
and it's funny not really funny but it's
true
SiC transit gloria glory fades glory
saves you've got carpe Noctem which I
know as seize the night from the
live-action role-playing game vampire
that my friends played back in college
you know we've got tempest edex rear um
which means time the devour of all
things I'm not sure if that's referring
to time the idea or Time Warner the
company but based on the quality of my
cable subscription it might be both
you've also got on this list of Draco
dorm Ian's nin qualms - Landes Tittel
andis never tickle a sleeping dragon yep
good advice and also a good life motto
Ultima force and which means perhaps the
last which is often also translated as
it's later than you think and appeared
on a lot of clock faces back in the day
to remind you every time you were
looking up the time that you were also
one minute or five minutes closer to
death oh yes John I love to say about
never tickle asleeping dragon I I've
never had an opportunity nor do I
imagine I will to tickle an actual
sleeping dragon however I do find myself
occasionally tempted to tickle a
sleeping baby
because no that's a terrible idea super
cute baby and I'm like I just want to
give you a little bit of and then it's
in the net like why why why have I made
this terrible decision I now have to
deal with this I just wanted to touch a
baby and now I got this thing
it was so good when it was sleeping oh
yeah that's what really what it should
be baby door me and snen qualms tipped
Atlantis I don't know what the Latin for
baby is yeah I like above all come a
compassion but to me it's no
illegitimate uncover undone that's right
John illegitimate non carborundum that's
just that's to you and bye-bye
illegitimate I mean your teeth this
question is from Cato who asks dear Hank
and John recently my friend Carrie who
calls me potato informed me that the
rocks and general terrain on Mars are
putting holes in the wheels of the
Curiosity rover apparently the river has
been driving backwards for some time now
in a tent in an attempt to make the
wheels last longer this upsets me how
much longer can curiosity continue to
give us gifts of discovery until it can
no longer move once it's stationary can
it still do research of any importance
to us will we have to wait for
astronauts to land on Mars to find out
more about the planet is Hanks actual
Mars news at risk it's true John I do
rely on curiosity for Mars news and if
we run out of curiosity we're gonna have
less though certainly not know Mars news
lots of Mars news still but less Mars
news so yeah that is a problem in the
Mars 2020 Rover which we are developing
right now is gonna have a different
wheel design for this very reason but at
the moment it's it's a it's a concern
and and we're much more careful about
how we drive the rover now now that we
know that these these wheel holes are a
thing but it's a heavy Rover and it's
got you know it's wheels are built to be
lightweight because everything is on it
to the is built to be lightweight and it
turned out that they were a little less
durable than we had hoped the Curiosity
rover does have a lifespan that is more
determined by its power source that its
wheels but even once it is no longer
mobile it will be calm
a stationary science experiment on Mars
and it will continue giving us good data
possibly for 10 years or more as the
opportunity Rover has shown which is
still operational on the surface of Mars
after having had a planned life of like
six months it's ten years later and it's
still going
so more than 10 years and very very a
testament to how fantastic NASA
engineers are at making things that can
can live the test of time Hank I think
that you failed to address the most
important part of this question so I
just want to stop you if I can
did you or did you not point out that
this person's name appears to be Cato
potater s'en oh there's potato so the
real last name well I mean it is the
name that they signed off with oh and
you guys potato sand and yeah it's a
thing if there is a person in the world
named potater s'en and there do appear
to be several judging from facebook
specifically by several i mean three
that's the best how how have I gone
through life so long without knowing
that I could use potater s'en as a last
name in one of my novels well I worry
no no Margo Roth Spiegelman could have
been Margo Roth potater Minh you know I
guess is John my guess is that this
person's last name is Peterson and that
they have added a potato into a
portmanteau of their name and have made
themselves potater s'en because I
clicked on Jeffrey potater s'en the only
potato sand on Facebook and yet is just
a picture of a person drawn onto a
potato that is true also I'm now reading
Jeffrey potater syns status updates and
they do seem to be potato centric for
instance some people like unloaded and
some people like me plain I think that
is a bit of a double entendre and
previously it's there's one that says
this is a picture of my parents I know
it's a bit inappropriate but it was the
only picture I had of them and it
appears
to be two potatoes situated in such a
way that they are simulating the whatnot
and also Geoffrey potatoes and has has
posted just got out of the oven so baked
right now I mean just I have not added a
friend on Facebook in like literally
seven years until today I've just sent a
friend request to Geoffrey potater s'en
I will let you know if he gets back to
me yeah I mean Geoffrey potato son has a
bunch of friends ten of them and started
high school that Burnsville high school
on may 5th 2011 so I don't really know
how that worked but hasn't hasn't
updated since January of 2012 Chuck so
we'll see how that goes I'm gonna go
ahead and add that friend as well
all right hick our next question comes
from Benjamin who writes Dear John and
Hank when I first started going to my
hairstylist I gave the phone number for
my dad's membership card and when she
said his name I just confirmed and since
then she thinks that that's my name I've
been going to her for many years now but
I don't have the heart to tell her the
lie that we've been living I don't want
to admit the truth
but haircuts should be built on trust
right what do I do dftba benjamin ah
you just got eats gotta live this lie in
fact you might want to change your name
completely and let everybody know that
you in and not let them know why and the
only person that you're not letting know
about your name change is your
hairdresser right that's one strategy I
think another strategy is to go into
your hairstylist and when they're like
so how have things been going the last
six to ten weeks you say you know the
biggest thing that happened in the last
ten weeks was that I went to the
courthouse and I decided to change my
name to Benjamin and now I am a Benjamin
for the rest of my life and it's a new
thing it's a fresh start for me I've
always kind of wanted to be a Benjamin
and now I am one and your hairstyles
will be like cool so should I start
calling you Benjamin and you'd be like I
mean that'd be great yeah it's my name
you solved the whole problem
it's totally solved it's totally okay I
don't have it
and so rare that we're able to actually
fix people's problem yeah that feels
great yeah there's I can I ask you John
is the phrase hairdresser a weird a
weird phrase because that you don't they
don't like dress you like it makes me
picture two things either they're
putting clothes on your hair or they're
putting putting salad dressing in it
that's the only things that I dress I
definitely prefer hairstylist so I
talked to David about this who's my hair
stylist and he prefers hair stylist but
I think different people use different
words and it's mostly about listening to
your hair
professional on what they want to be
called yes just like your hair
professional should listen to you
Benjamin about what you want to be
called this question is from Cole who
asks dear Hank and John what I have to
go number two I've noticed that the
sensation sometimes comes in waves in
some time in some moments I feel that I
need to run to the bathroom in the
moments later I feel as though nothing
is wrong and then soon after it feels as
though I will have to go at any moment
I'm hoping I'm not the only person who
experiences this wouldn't it be easier
for my body to tell me when I have to go
badly when I end what I don't have to go
badly
why does my body do this an avid pod
listener on the throne Cole hmm what do
you know about about pooping John not
much but I am familiar with that
phenomenon I call it contractions which
Sara takes exception to yeah I actually
do know something about this I think
both because I am in a bit of an
aficionado of pooping but also I know
about how the human body works a little
bit better than the average person your
so you have a basically a spot on the
inside of your rectum that when it
experiences pressure it's like now is
the time to go and it actually creates a
little bit of a positive feedback loop
where it will open and that will allow
for more pressure and that will open it
more and that's why could be hard to not
poop and that and and the lake the
reason that that spot will be
experiencing pressure is cuz the rectum
is not empty but also because your body
all the way from your mouth on down has
these muscle contractions that go in
waves and it's almost like a
like you're milking a cow like your take
the other and then you're like squeezing
it down and like that's what's happening
that it forced that's what forces food
and stuff through your digestive system
and at the end they're like when you're
getting one of those waves that's when
you feel oh I'm feeling the pressure now
and that spotted your rectum is saying
poop time and then that wave will stop
because it comes in waves and then you
won't be experiencing that pressure
anymore and things will be able to like
go back up a little bit but I will say
that if you felt one of those waves you
can usually intentionally make one
happen by going to the toilet and it
will happen automatically even if you
don't feel like you have to poop at that
moment if you've had one recently you
probably will go wow that's why that
happens interesting well and it really
wasn't really a funny answer Chuck
III didn't know that I'd come to this
party to learn about that but I'm glad I
did I'm sure I'm sure
we've got another question Hank it comes
from Leanne and this is kind of up your
alley she writes dear John and Hank our
solar panel is designed to work with the
light from any star or just our son like
if Tony Stark invented a solar powered
suit and was then transported to a
different solar system would he still be
able to charge his suit thank you for
the answers the poems of sorry about the
lack of poems Leon and the news sorry
about the lack of news Leanne not a
descendent of Beyonce Leanne you're not
yet but the good news is Leanne that
your descendants will be someday that's
right that's absolutely right John
no our solar panels or that we make are
optimized for our Sun optimized for the
wavelengths that come off of our Sun and
also the wavelengths that make it
through our atmosphere so at least the
ones that we use on earth are so our
atmosphere scatters certain certain
wavelengths and so the light that makes
it to the surface of the earth is mostly
like that we in what we call the visible
spectrum and the solar panels that we
design are made to absorb light in that
spectrum and other stars brown dwarfs
red dwarfs red giants there are some
whiter stars out there some bluer
stars they would like certainly our
solar panels would be able to work in
those places but you could design better
solar panels for those stars quick quick
follow-up question Hank what our solar
panels work well on Mars yes because
well first we've developed solar panels
that work in space and they're basically
the same thing but it's mostly the the
light that is being emitted by the star
that matters so our our solar panels
would work just fine on on Mars and
indeed in outer space which they do
right now well I guess that's
encouraging for those of us who think
that it's a good idea to go to Mars
which I don't think it's a terrible idea
I think I think that I think there's a
right time in a wrong time for
everything in the human life and the
right time to go to Mars is in 2028 or
later all right John this question okay
I have another question Hank oh you know
you go you're right okay this question
is from Caitlin who asks dear Hank and
John why does cookie dough taste so much
better than the cookies after they've
been baked is it the texture the
temperature any answer for this would be
appreciated Stay Gold Ponyboy Caitlin
yeah that's a fantastic sign-off Stay
Gold Ponyboy is in my top 10 all time
dear Hank and John sign house I don't
know what it's from is it from something
oh my god what is it like to be able to
know so much about pooping and not know
Stay Gold Ponyboy did you never read The
Outsiders as a child Hank are you
actually when someone gave me a copy of
The Outsiders at nerdcon nerdfighteria
and is sitting on my kitchen island well
it will take you two and a half hours to
read and it is a really great novel they
also made a very good movie out of it
that you could just watch the movie if
you want it's like a classic why a novel
it is one of the founding novels of the
Y Hashanah it comes from a Robert Frost
poem but I'm surprised I've never read
to you because it's so short I'll read
it to you right now it's one of my
favorite Robert Frost poems nature's
first green is gold her hardest hue to
hold her early Leafs of flower but only
so an hour then leaf subsides to leaf so
Eden sank down to grief so dawn goes
down today nothing gold can stay
nothing gold can stay but stay gold
Ponyboy oh god it's so good I gotta say
John that was better than the poem we
started out with today I feel like just
a little bit better yeah yep you know I
have a good friend who said that Robert
Frost never wrote a poem that a
reasonably intelligent fourth grader
couldn't understand but I kind of think
that's a compliment yeah so yeah anyway
why does cookie dough tastes better than
cookies you know I'm not sure that it
does no I prefer cookie I think that it
tastes different yeah III there are
times when I want both like you know
what's real good John is you take a
cookie like a cooked cookie cooked
chocolate chip cookie and then you
spread cookie don't want it and you eat
it like and then you put another cookie
on top of that and it's a cookie dough
cookie sandwich boom mmm five stars to
Hank green I'm selling those that from
now on that's don't nobodies take that
idea it's mine yo did you see I mean you
couldn't possibly have invented that
idea I don't care I definitely did just
invent that idea I'm googling it though
it's a great I mean I have to say it is
a really really good idea I don't know
that it's safe because I feel like
cookie dough might have some Salmonella
implications that's why I always mind I
mean you can make cookie dough without
without I can't make cookie dough with
make it without raw eggs it's hard to
imagine how you make cookie dough
without eggs you would have to use a egg
substitute John a which sometimes egg
substitutes are made from eggs but
they've gone through a process that
sterilizes them so it's like the cookie
dough that they put in like Ben and
Jerry's ice cream like that cookie dough
doesn't have raw eggs in it really I
always thought I was taking a risk with
with chocolate chip cookie dough ice
cream it's good to know that I'm not
yeah I like it
yeah no you're good but but there is
there is something to it and and I I
can't I can't tell you I don't have the
science there but I know that from my
personal preference sometimes I want one
sometimes they want it's a really really
good idea Hank for a frozen treat that's
like you know those those frozen treats
that you can get where it's two
chocolate chip cookies and in the middle
it's
scream I can't remember what they're
actually called but if you just a
Chipwich sure if you just put frozen
cookie dough in that middle you could
have some magic on your hands that's an
interesting concept I'd like to see you
take it to market our next question
comes from Lucy who writes Dear John and
Hank I'd greatly appreciate some dubious
advice I'm 19 and I've been best friends
with a girl for three and a half years
I'm also a girl and we are incredibly
close about two months ago we started
making out I didn't know if I liked her
so we decided to kiss I felt I probably
wanted to kiss her because we were so
close now we've been doing it for two
months and enjoying it a lot as well as
seeing each other almost every day I
can't imagine my life or future without
her we don't know if we're in love
though I've always heard that you just
know when you're in love but I feel like
my situation might be different how can
you tell if you're in love with someone
when you already love them deeply as a
best friend is it easy to mix up
romantic love with friendship love plus
sex how would I break this news to
family and friends who would be
extremely shocked to discover our
relationship is not platonic so many
questions beetroot and polar bears
Lucy is that is that an office reference
like very abstractly beets and bears and
Battlestar Galactica I don't know I
don't get I I didn't think a joke I
don't I'm not you you could this is
another place where our world of
references does not have a ton of
overlap like I get jokes about the
outsiders like I get jokes about the
outsiders and you get jokes about the
office so it's good we compliment each
other anyway yes Hank how do you know
the difference between romantic love and
friendship love and how do you know that
you're in love I I don't know like the
I'm I it definitely when it starts as
friendship it's a different thing and
and maybe like you have a little bit
less of that like you know heart in your
throat kind of feeling where it's like
this is really happening and oh my god
and this and I love this this person
likes me and it's so much and it's like
this positive feedback loop of affection
and infatuation that is the thing that
is like being in love and which is a
wonderful feeling but and
not necessarily the most important
feelings they're ever gonna feel but to
me it's like a friend that I want to
hook up with like somebody who I cared
really deeply about and also want to
have relations with like that's kind of
is that is that love asks the 36 year
old man I don't know I think that's why
I wanted to ask the question because I
think it's complicated I I kind of agree
with you that there is a culturally
celebrated idea of being in love where
you just know and it clicks all at once
and there's no doubt in your mind that
you're in love and it's instantaneous
and overwhelming and the candle is
burning at both ends and will not last
the night and etc but like I have found
that the most fulfilling romantic
relationships I've had were with people
I cared really deeply about as friends
like when Sarah and I started dating we
were we really liked each other as
people before we ever started kissing
that like the attraction the initial
attraction was definitely an
intellectual friendship attraction
rather than you know an intense romantic
attraction but you know when the
romantic attraction came it was powerful
and an important part of our
relationship obviously so I I mean I
think you've got a Lucy when you say
like you've heard that people just know
I I don't think that I've said this
before but I don't think that love is
like a station on it like like a train
stop or something you know it's not like
a place you arrived at and then stay in
for a certain amount of time or forever
it's more of like a seat for me at least
like it's more of a process than an
event if that makes sense
uh-huh yeah definitely I think most
things are more processes than events
though events are so overrated and
processes are so underrated yeah I mean
it's hard to it's hard like it's that
thing like there's a moment and you can
celebrate a moment we have this problem
all our all over our society and even
all over my life
we're like you in a way societies like
the reason we create ritual is to give
the significance of an event to the
reality of the process and and like
marriage to me is that same thing like
marriage isn't right like a it's not
like a binary switch where you're like
you're married and then you're not
married like that's how it is legally
but we've made it that way in order to
give significance to the process of
becoming a committed couple and mmin so
you've got and like you in like things
like birthdays are a little bit that way
and coming-of-age ceremonies like
graduations are that way
where you've we and in a way sometimes
they can cheapen the process by making
it all about this one moment and so like
the four years of high school become all
about this one moment of graduation when
in fact they were about every moment in
which you became a better and and
smarter and you know more full human
being through the process of learning
about the world and how to do stuff and
how to interact with people right ya
know and then you end up like you end up
being really focused on the event of a
wedding rather than on the marriage I I
see that all the time where you know you
just get so into planning the wedding
and making sure that the wedding is
perfect and the wedding is successful in
like really when I look back at my
engagement by far the most important
parts were the parts where we were
talking about what our marriage was
kinda like yeah it's not what your
wedding was gonna be part so we're
talking about which flowers were gonna
be at our wedding or not the part 12
years later and think like boy I'm glad
we had that conversation well I mean I
don't know that that's helps
particularly with Lucy's question but no
we're we're we're way off the rails Hank
and I don't really I don't really know
but I think that if you like this person
a lot and also like the romantic
relationship you have with them then
think about the you know the now of it
and
and appreciate the now of it and do you
have to create do you have to like fit
this relationship into the tropes of how
we talk about relationships or can you
find a way to appreciate it for exactly
what it is and understand it from your
own perspective rather than from the
perspective of how everybody else thinks
about romantic love all right Hank let's
move on to another question this
question comes from Grace who says I've
been thinking about this one problem or
idea or situation pretty much my entire
life also hi I'm grace longtime
nerdfighter big fan of the pod when is
enough really enough particularly with
money I've been thinking about John's
comment on how he was pretty much
anthropologically studying rich people
and he has witnessed that while we think
we will be more generous and useful when
we have money we really aren't in
general because we are human and our
desires grow right along with our
wallets and almost as a rule always
outgrows them so how do we measure our
necessary money / wealth and to
determine how much to donate or give
away or use for not us centered things
Oh John this is a good question and I
think about this a lot as well grace it
is a thing that that is constantly on my
mind and a little bit makes me
uncomfortable because I'm thinking about
other people and how they should do
things maybe more than I'm thinking
about me and how I should do things but
so rich people really do donate less of
their money percentage-wise to charity
than people in the middle class and I am
fascinated by this phenomenon where
people who make $50,000 a year don't
think twice about pledging 10 percent of
their income to charity or to their
church or however they give back but
people who make 5 million dollars a year
think like well you can't give five
hundred thousand dollars to charity and
so it really is true that people in the
upper income brackets give a much
smaller percentage on average of their
wealth to charity than people who are in
lower income
brackets and I think that is because it
genuinely never feels like enough there
is always one more thing that you want
to have I mean in this email Hank grace
goes on to talk about how for a long
time she was living in a car with her
partner in order to save money and still
felt a lot of guilt about the money that
she was spending so you know when I'm
when I'm like hanging out with people
who belong to country clubs you know the
level of cognitive dissonance is
overwhelming but like the level of
cognitive dissonance in my own life is
also overwhelming right because i stiii
do all kinds of things and buy all kinds
of things that are ridiculous and
completely unnecessary and it's and that
are very hard to justify so i have no
idea where the line is I don't think
that I draw it well in my own life but I
don't also don't want to be looking to
make more money because in my own life I
I think I have known that it doesn't
make me more happy yeah like it made me
more happy for a while but then I hit a
wall after which it didn't really
increase my happiness much yeah I mean I
mean I think it's worth noting that
there's a there's there's just a
weirdness to economic inequality and and
people don't think people don't think in
terms of percentages but the world
operates in terms of percentages so you
know if you have $500,000 and you
invested in the stock market and the
stock market goes up 10% then you made a
lot more money than somebody who had you
know $5,000 in the stock market and
that's how that works and when you have
more money you can make more money but
it also seems like well shouldn't we all
kind of give the same amount in terms of
absolute dollars because like five
hundred thousand dollars to charity is a
like that's a lot like I don't even know
how to do that without without like
messing up a charity's finances like if
the charity is too small you could like
and you want to give them a one-time
gift you could mess stuff up it's you
almost have too much power in that
responsibility becomes like scary or you
don't know how to wield it properly or
you start to convince yourself that
people aren't gonna do as good a thing
with that money that you would do you
also start to feel like it's yours you
know I mean there's a weirdness to
that's something that I Bill Gates said
to me when I visited Ethiopia with him
not to drop names that was the worst
name drop I've ever done in my life but
this is this is true you know he he
never talks about giving money away he
always talks about giving money back as
if it really isn't yeah you know his now
that noted Bill Gates lives a very nice
life you know I mean III don't think
Bill Gates is wanting for any of the any
of the material joys of the world but I
do appreciate that lots of people who
have billions of dollars don't give back
because they think that the money is
truly deeply theirs and I just I don't I
don't feel that way so I guess I I don't
know I I don't have a good answer to
this grace I think it's really hard and
complicated and I am trying in my life
to give more back and take less yeah I
also think that as you know there's just
percentage-wise there's a lot of like a
fairly large number of people who listen
this podcast who have a lot of money
because in the last 10 years we've all
heard that you know the majority
economic gains of the of the recovery
went to the the rich and that means that
a lot of people in the last 10 years
have gotten pretty wealthy and more and
more people are kind of having to deal
with the fact that they have the ability
to have an outsized amount of influence
and and that maybe they're feeling even
guilty about the money that they do have
and don't know what to do with it and so
i i've been thinking about and i've also
am in that situation and so i've been
thinking more about like how do we
structure society in a way that actually
allows those benefits to not just affect
such as tiny number of people and and
and i like i feel like it's such a big
question though that it can eat like a
it needs at least a it needs several
books to
deal with it and I hope that people are
writing this books right now because I
want to read them I yeah i mean i think
wealth inequality is the biggest the
biggest war one of the biggest problems
facing the rich countries in the world
right now I mean yeah wealth inequality
is one of those things that really is
getting significantly worse I think a
lot of human life is getting better but
wealth inequality is getting much worse
and that's not just bad yeah I think
that's bad morally but if you just put
aside the ethical questions the moral
considerations it's also bad for
economic growth it's bad for economies
to have so much unfairness built into
the system where you know some people
get huge leg legs up because they have
access to educational opportunities and
you know unpaid internships and all
kinds of other opportunities and that
doesn't end up making you know an
economy where everybody has equal
opportunities and where lots and lots of
people can be maximally innovative it
ends up creating this really unequal
economy and you know yeah it's a big
concern to me
which reminds me John that this podcast
is actually brought to you by huge legs
up the plural of huge leg up possibly is
it huge leg ups or huge we you know
you're not entirely sure but huge legs
up fighting to be the plural of huge leg
up and of course today's podcast is
brought to you by Jeffrey potaters and
Jeffrey potater s'en Facebook's only
potater 'sin additionally this podcast
is of course brought to you by Hank
Green's brand new chocolate-chip cookie
dough cookie sandwiches cookie to
cookies with cookie dough on the inside
it'll make you squeal with a heart
disease cookie dough cookie sandwiches I
hate greed I think you might want to
work on the branding a little bit there
Hank I'm on it people don't like okay
yeah good idea all right
and lastly today's podcast is brought to
you by time time really not a very good
cable provider okay also the Devourer of
all things
I mean it's so true it's so true okay
I've got a question for you and you
won't on
Stan why I'm asking it for like the
first two thirds or so of the question
but then you will understand this
question comes from Alison who writes
okay dear brothers green although she
said that in French and I don't know how
to say stuff in French so I just
translated it I am an English professor
who's been teaching Charlotte brontë's
novel Villette I might have said that
wrong in rereading the book with my
class I came across my favorite line
from the book again the main character
Lucy snow has been suffering from what I
think we would today called depression
she calls it despair and a fever of the
nerves that's actually a really good
phrase fever of the nerves I can I can
that resonates her friend / doctor tells
her that the cure is to quote cultivate
happiness in response she thinks no
mockery in this world ever sounds to me
so hollow as that of being told to
cultivate happiness
what does such a vise mean happiness is
not a potato to be planted in mold and
tilled with manure so my question is if
happiness is not a potato what vegetable
is it also can happy to speak hope your
dear reader Allison I just thought this
is an important question to ask given
the discovery of Jeffrey potato soon and
in general you know our own orientation
toward trying to cultivate happiness
Hank what vegetable is happiness for me
it's a cauliflower mmm cauliflower I
mean I don't know John of the Heinz team
seems like a pretty bland vegetable for
happiness not ever again say that
cauliflower is a bland vegetable okay I
will not ever again say that cauliflower
is a planned vegetable out of respect to
my brother John Green good lord
cauliflower is delicious and amazing and
it's one of the world's healthiest foods
according to world's healthiest foods
calm so shut your mouth I'm sure you
look that one up John I did I did I was
googling cauliflower to try to learn
some things about it really quickly so
that I could defend it against your
accusations that is bland
Hank do you know that cauliflower was
Napoleon Bonaparte's favorite food no it
I don't know that that's true it's a
it's a speculation on my part
I you know John I'm making a guess but
it's an educated guess because it's
cauliflower is delicious so it's totally
possible do you know that there's such a
thing as purple cauliflower yeah I have
heard of this
John how do you so I would say that
purple cauliflower is the vegetable that
you have to cultivate like happiness so
that's my that's my final so you can
cultivate if you can cultivate happiness
and happiness as a cauliflower how do
you cultivate that cauliflower happiness
hey can you name the three nations that
produce the most cauliflower I'm gonna
go with the United States of America
third and two other countries India and
China second in first you know I
probably I probably yep should have gone
for India and China makes a lot of sense
china produces nearly half of the
overall world cauliflower so I guess the
first thing you want to do if you want
to cultivate happiness is move to China
because that seems to be the number one
place to cultivate cauliflower yeah
that's a great question because
happiness is not a potato you know what
I think John happiness is a sugar snap
pea for me that's what it would be Oh
so bitter you oh you just you have not
had good snap peas John oh no I did and
they've got that like they've got that
line that goes through them that
sometimes gets stuck in your teeth
no oh man you got it you got to get some
good snap peas I'm I'm sad for you move
out here to Montana where we make them
good Hank do you know the three leading
cultivators of sugar snap peas is it the
United States no I don't know the answer
it wasn't a rhetorical question I just
wanted to point out that I I know more
about cauliflower than you will ever
even know about sugar snap peas that's
definitely true I I could I even tried
to google it and failed um Hank if you
ever read any of the iTunes reviews of
our podcast dear Hank and John so many
of the iTunes reviews are like I really
like Hank but John is so annoying and I
always think like that doesn't make any
sense I'm so incredibly fun and cool and
great and that's not nice but then like
joke was a total example of me being
tremendously annoying so I want to
apologize I I've been having a hard time
listening to anything this podcast
because I have this giant google image
search up on my computer of cookie dough
cookie sandwiches and it is so beautiful
that I can't think about anything else
let me look cookie it is it is by the
way John a thing that many people have
done at least in their own homes oh yeah
you did not invent this this is this has
been developed extensively my god all of
those yes delicious there is not an
image on this google image search that I
would not greatly enjoy eating right now
good yeah like how long do I have to
scroll down before I find something I
wouldn't eat oh wow that is that is
magnificent I love that ma'am I wouldn't
eat him I don't know why there's just a
man here well I'm glad we I'm glad you
scrolled down to the part where you just
start to see humans um Hank let's let's
get to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon because it's so important and
I know that it's the real reason why
people come to this podcast so what is
the news from Mars this week um the news
from Mars John so you know how Mars does
not have a magnetic field I do oh that
reminds me though that the magnetic
fields have released a really great new
album so everybody check that out okay
and the the primary way that bag Bennet
field of Earth helps us it's not just in
figuring out which way is north but also
in protecting us from the radiation that
is being thrown out by the Sun and form
of the solar wind and if you were on the
surface of Mars you would not be
protected from that radiation and it
would hurt you and eventually you would
probably get cancer and die so once
ocean to this problem is to just have
all the houses on Mars be underground
which is kind of a sad solution because
you'd have to live underground and
people like not living underground and
also it would be you know you'd have to
spend some time not underground so a
alternate solution to this problem which
could also potentially be used in outer
space vessels and could also John you
love this potentially be used to protect
the Earth from an apocalypse causing
high-level solar flare that would knock
out all electricity in the whole world
would be - that is great you create a
thing that is not on the planet but sits
out in space and creates a high level
magnetic field probably with like two
very strong magnets spinning around each
other in some way and I'm not entirely
sure about how this works but it's a
thing that they are actually trying to
figure out right now and it in those
three situations one to be sent out to
protect the Earth from high-level solar
flares to be used in spacecraft to
protect astronauts from the radiation
and interplanetary space and to protect
potentially a future Mars colony by
basically protecting the entire planet
so it would be out in space and it would
be like if it was on the planet it would
block a smaller amount of the radiation
but if it was out in space it would give
it sort of like a cone that could move
out from there and widen enough to
protect the whole planet with a much
smaller device ooh and and I think that
that's super cool and NASA is
legitimately looking into how to create
these things both to protect astronauts
that might go to another planet but also
to protect Earth from this thing that
happens sometimes and that hasn't
happened really since we started relying
so extensively on electricity to
maintain our lifestyles and and could
potentially prevent straight-up
apocalypse so I had some good news for
you mark John I I almost called you Mars
and I hope yeah thanks for calling me
Mars made me feel like Bruno Mars for a
second I felt great also it's like I
care about you and the way that I care
about a planet well the news from AFC
Wimbledon is not quite so bright tank
which is that AFC Wimbledon's captain
Barry Fuller who's a great guy
I've hung out with him a couple times I
hung out with him after the League Two
play-off final and we were both very
happy I think we
he might have even been happier than I
was it was just an incredible moment I
got to meet his kids I got a picture
with his kids and his and his lovely
spouse and he's just a great guy and a
real asset to the club in terms of his
leadership and unfortunately he is going
to miss the rest of AFC Wimbledon's
season because he tore a pectoral he had
to get surgery actually and that just
sounds so everything else aside that
just sounds astonishingly painful so
we're sending our best wishes to mr.
fuller and his family and it seems that
he'll be out for several months but
hopefully back at the start of next
season although I think even that might
be a challenge so we're wishing him well
and hoping for the best
I'm sorry to hear about that John but
the good news is that NASA is working on
a tool to protect him and also the rest
of humanity from high-energy solar
flares that is encouraging there's so
much to be hopeful about what did we
learn today John well I think most
importantly we learned that cookie dough
cookie sandwiches are both a thing and a
thing that I need to make tonight we
learned that you can dress three things
in the world you can dress people you
can dress hair and you can dress salads
we learned that there are many excellent
mottos especially if you're good at
Latin and finally we learned that the
the reason you feel like you got a poop
is because there's this wave of muscle
pushing stuff down into your rectum that
ways of life of muscle by the way is
called peristalsis and I'm so glad we
got to go back to that you can just
google that on up and find out more
about it thank you John for potting with
me today yeah no thank you
what how do we get the podcast again I
if you want a recipe for a cookie dough
cookie sandwich we're gonna put that up
on the patreon when this goes live yeah
so please check out our patreon at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
dear Hank and John is produced by
rosianna halse rojas I'm sure and Gibson
our editor is Nicholas Jenkins Victoria
Bonjour is our head of community and
communications our music is by the
great gunnarolla you can email us at a
Hank and John at gmail.com or find us on
the Twitter I'm John Green and Hank is
Hank green
I don't really tweet anymore so probably
your best bet is at Leon must for Earth
that's number four earth that's right
Hank thanks for thanks for you know Leon
must for Earth has been listing his
favorite Mars is lately Hank Mars the
candy bar of course Bruno Mars there's a
Mars in New Mexico that Leon must is
quite fond of I'll tell you I don't like
to brag but Leon muss has some
incredible social media presence all
right John thanks we're parting with me
thanks to everybody for listening and as
they say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
[Music]